this week on the climate show as we race
to plant millions of trees who's looking
after them to stop this happening it's
completely dead
and thousands more along here have got
the same fate
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heap this week a glamorous
location a Motorway embankment in
Cambridgeshire surrounded by dead trees
and we'll be asking why we're obsessed
with planting them rather than making
sure they grow also on the show as the
U.S proposes strict new limits on the
levels of cancer causing so-called
forever chemicals and drinking water we
look at whether anything is being done
to address the problem here at home
and with Monday being world rewilding
day we'll take you to a pioneering
project in Kent as it welcomes its
latest residence
but first to trees governments companies
Charities councils are often falling
over themselves to have ambitious tree
planting targets to sequester carbon or
provide a home for wildlife but as you
can see here planting them is one thing
making sure they survived their first
birthday is quite another
the upgrade of this 21-mile section of
the A14 between Cambridge and Huntington
cost one and a half billion pounds was
opened in 2020 and resulted in the
planting of 860 000 trees
three is on the traffic's running quite
freely but how are the saplings doing no
Tree in there no Tree in there and
nutrient there no something like 70 of
the 860
000 trees that were planted have died
that's over half a million trees yeah
and why
I guess National highways didn't have a
plan they have to consider what trees
they plant in what kind of place and
what sort of support and maintenance
they provide the trees so that they do
actually get established planting trees
here is more than just a feel-good
nicety they got permission for this
bypass what's called a development
consent order on the basis that
landscaping and trees would be put in
place and that is one reason why
National highways admit they now need a
replanting strategy
National highways declined to do an
interview but subsequently published a
press release admitting an unusually
high failure rate among planted trees
and told us the cost of replanting will
be around 2.9 million pounds that's
taxpayers Money Tree Experts we've
spoken to say the survival rate of new
trees is a national problem and it stems
from an obsession with planting numbers
not least of the last election
two billion trees by 2040. the planting
of millions of trees planting 60 million
trees a year Michael Downs is an
arboriculturalist with 30 years
experience Mike this is the key you can
plant a tree it might cost you say 20
pounds out of 100 to plant the tree but
the other 80 should be spent on the
maintenance because the establishment of
the trees that's the hardest job they do
the weather in the last couple of years
a dry spring and a scorching summer have
been tough for young trees making that
care even more important so how do you
ensure a sapling will prosper not wither
what's the plan with him over there
we're making a small Woodland about the
size of a football pitch lovely where
they're the first trees Carol honey bun
Kelly worked with the Woodland trust for
eight years and is now planning a cops
alongside a riding Charity's new
facility so why the carpet Carol well
this is a mulch mat or something that
suppresses weeds and keeps the moisture
in underneath there is no point planting
without Aftercare otherwise you'll come
back in six or eight months time and
it'll still be this it's not as sexy to
talk about maintenance and weeding trees
and it's not as top line for your
corporate responsibility web pages but
it is so important and in your
experience is that Aftercare handling no
it isn't what's at stake what's at stake
well the bird's not going to perch on
that it's not going to work on carbon
for you it's not going to stop soil
erosion this little thing here but if
you look after it if you plant it and
within two three seven years it will be
starting to deliver they have to grow
not just be planted they have to grow
please grow
but will that happen as even the head of
the government agency that Champions
trees questions the political emphasis
is there too much focus on planting
perhaps are not enough on actually
growing surviving of those trees it's
easy to talk about planting it's easy to
talk about planting targets planting is
just the start of the journey I would
like to see much more money put into
management as well as planting how
important is tree planting and survival
to our Net Zero goals very very
important if we don't get Survival it's
nothing planting trees is the most cost
effective way to manage carbon it's
absolutely essential planting rates are
also running at less than half what was
pledged at the last election so fewer
saplings with less survival bad news for
our nature and climate aims
now on to a big story from the US that
could well have impacts here and it's
all about new limits that the American
government is putting on over what they
consider a very toxic chemical this is
something called pfas and the reason
people are worried about these chemicals
is they last so long in the environment
and indeed in our bodies and there's a
lot of concern that they could be having
an impact even at pretty low levels well
I'm joined to talk about this by uh Zach
Schaefer who is from the water office at
the U.S Environmental Protection Agency
where he's a senior advisor and he joins
me from Washington Zach very nice to
hear from you just tell us what are pfas
and why should people be concerned Why
have you put in these new lower limits
pfas are a category of several thousand
manufactured chemicals actually that can
cause serious health problems if you're
exposed to them over a long period of
time now we we continue to use them
they've been used for many decades
because they have useful characteristics
they make our our pots and pans
non-stick they're used in waterproof
clothing and firefighting foam and stain
resistant carpets and in manufacturing
processes some pfas have been phased out
due to health and environmental concerns
but there are thousands that are still
found in many products and as you said
they tend to break down very slowly in
the environment and can build up in our
bodies and in animals over time
and what are those Health impacts what
kind of things are we talking about the
science is very clear that that
long-term exposure to certain pfas is
linked to real health risks uh the the
exposure over a long period of time and
at certain critical stages in people's
lives like during pregnancy or early
childhood can lead to negative effects
on pregnant women and developing babies
it can weaken the body's ability to
fight disease it can increase risk for
some cancers liver damage and elevated
cholesterol which of course can lead to
risk for heart attack and stroke now we
know no one's got any doubt that at very
high levels these can be extremely toxic
famously was the film dark Waters came
out a few years ago looked at a very
high levels in a particular town where
they're being manufactured what is the
evidence that they can have an impact on
much lower levels and therefore
presumably why you brought in these
lower limits yes so that the latest
science does indicate that health
effects can occur at extremely low
levels much lower more than were
previously known and that's why we've
proposed this Rule and I want to be
clear that this is a proposed rule it
still has to go through a process here
in the United States to to finalize it
uh but that science indicates that uh
that health effects can occur at
extremely low levels and that's why
we've set the limit for certain pfas for
pfoa and pfos for instance at four parts
per trillion and for four other pfas at
a um a similarly low maximum contaminant
level so
trillion that is incredibly low and I'm
I'm trying to think of you know whether
that's a kind of blade of grass in a
baseball stadium or a football stadium
you know but we're talking those kind of
really difficult to find levels aren't
we it is and one of the reasons that we
are setting the levels that low of
course is that we you know
consume drinking water regularly over
the course of their day over the course
of their lives and so we want to set a
level that the science tells us will
provide maximum protection based on the
available treatment Technologies and
filtration systems available that will
protect people over the course of their
lives so that's why these levels are so
low because over the course of their
lives I drink a lot of water and it
could build up has anyone done any
estimates of I don't know what what are
the the health effects in terms of
numbers I mean is this considered to be
a sort of un on previously kind of
unquantified Health minutes Public
Health Menace in the U.S I mean do you
suspect that thousands or tens of
thousands of premature deaths might be
down to this so we did a very robust uh
analysis of the the costs and benefits
as a part of the rulemaking process here
which we do following the safe drinking
water acts regulatory requirements and
we did uh determine that over over time
this rule it finalized this these levels
will save thousands of lives and prevent
tens of thousands of illnesses uh that
would be attributable to these pfas we
all want to protect Public Health the
science is clear that these chemicals uh
carry risks we really believe that safe
drinking water is fundamental to healthy
people and thriving communities and that
every person should have access to clean
and safe drinking water and that's why
we're acting now
um to protect people's drinking water
from pfas contamination well thank you
very much indeed Zach and as we saw said
there these chemicals are not just
linked to the United States they're
manufactured and have been used here in
the UK as well and we've got a report
now from a couple of journalists who've
been investigating at what levels they
might be here and they've taken to the
water to do it
foreign
[Music]
and this is my colleague Rachel Salvage
and we are environmental journalists for
Watershed and we've been investigating
forever chemical pollution here in the
UK which isn't as well known as the
problem is in America that doesn't mean
we don't have a problem
thank you
we found it in the Thames here at
Teddington and we found it all along the
river it could have got into the river
in so many ways because forever
chemicals are in so many consumer
products and Industrial processes but
we've also found it in high levels in
sewage effluent so wastewater treatment
works will pump it out and it'll get
into the rivers that way
in the United States they've proposed
lowering the maximum amount allowed in
drinking water to four parts per
trillion but here in the UK they allow a
lot more pfas in our drinking water up
to a hundred parts per trillion in the
water here at the Thames the water has
been sampled and it's been found
particularly kind of pfast was found
here at 60 parts per trillion further
down towards Battersea in the sediments
down there it was found at 5 000 parts
per trillion and it was also found in
fish here at 10 000 parts per trillion
so you would not want to be eating that
you would not want to touch that
so it looks like the UK are basically
trailing behind the United States and
some other countries in regulating how
much toxic chemicals they're allowing
into our Waters
[Music]
foreign work on the Thames there but as
we heard earlier perhaps the critical
thing is the level in drinking water so
we ask the government if they plan to
introduce tighter regulations like they
have in the states and they told us that
we have some of the highest drinking
water quality in the world before adding
we are working at PACE to assess the
levels of pfas occurring in the
environment to inform future policy they
also say they'll have an update in the
spring now moving on this week saw the
budget and this is what Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt had to say about nuclear
energy
increasing nuclear capacity is vital to
meet our Net Zero obligations so to
encourage private sector investment into
our nuclear program I today confirm that
subjects to consultation nuclear power
will be classed as environmentally
sustainable
[Applause]
[Music]
being low carbon nuclear of course has
some issues principally what to do with
all that radioactive waste well our
science correspondent Thomas Moore has
been in Cumbria discovering there are
some plans to bury it there
the government is promising a new
generation of nuclear power stations but
already highly radioactive waste is
piling up now seller field and 19 other
sites around the UK are storing waste
the size of six and a half thousand
double decker buses and it's got to go
somewhere the international consensus is
that it is best buried deep underground
and three areas along the cumbrian coast
and one on the east coast of England are
thought to be the right area for what's
called a geological disposal facility
and that's because the Bedrock is stable
enough to hold that waste until the
radioactivity decays deep underground in
a stable geology you know we can show
that those environments have been stable
for millions of years much longer than
it will take for the radioactivity to
Decay to a safe level so we try to find
those environments to construct our
geological disposal facility and that
will be safe require no human
intervention after it's sealed it's not
just the geology that will determine
where this site is built there has to be
a willing community and the nuclear
waste Services the government agency is
having a dialogue with these communities
trying to engage them to understand the
risks and also the advantages and
they're holding engagement events and
this is what some of the people told us
when we were there it is important that
there is you know economic growth in the
area and this would be a major you know
source for local people and hopefully if
it comes here that you know that will
benefit and I don't just see the benefit
of the the jobs
creates the infrastructure that this
part of the world sadly lacks but not
all local residents are happy with the
proposals one former science teacher who
lives here believes that although deep
disposal is the right way forward for
nuclear waste Cumbria isn't the place to
do it there's too much water underground
and the rocks have got too many
fractures for this to be stable enough
in the long term they all know that the
geology is much better in the east of
the country where they could build a gdf
that's big enough for all the stuff they
want to put down it and they could build
it quicker
cheaper and better over there but
without the Willing Community because
they have no experience of nuclear no
and that's and that's
that's the real problem with this whole
process Finland has already carved out a
warrant of tunnels to bury their waste
and they'll start doing that in just a
few years time we are about 30 years
behind that process but the belief is
that they can engage the communities
they can find a geological site where
they can do this safely and it is the
long-term solution for Britain's nuclear
waste
thank you
now after the break we'll take you to a
woodland in Kent that has just welcomed
some new residents in an effort to make
it a much Wilder place
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show well Monday
Mark's world rewilding day yes there is
one and to mark this we've been down to
a place in Kent where they're
introducing more animals because they
say more of the indigenous original
Wilder animals will actually help
improve the habitat and lock up more
carbon they were famous in the past for
introducing the first bison back to the
UK well Sky's Milano veselenovich has
been down to check it out
Woodland in Kent wild animals are slowly
changing the landscape
that grazing part of a rewilding project
to turn this formerly commercial wood
into a thriving ecosystem we're using
natural processes this is the kind of
way historically that Landscapes that
have been managed with large herbivores
moving through the landscape rubbing up
against the trees that you see all
around us here naturally caucusing
species like the Birch and and the
chestnuts that all around us we open up
areas of for grasslands and heathland to
grow through naturally and all at the
same time the animals are depositing
their feces and creating habitats and
micro habitats for invertebrates that of
course encourages bird life to thrive as
well
and to help nature Thrive these Longhorn
cattle roamed the Hills
sharing the wood with Iron Age pigs a
hybrid between wild boars and domestic
pigs
while Ponies are among them too and they
don't mind a passing visitor as long as
there's a distance and we keep quiet
animals here like these ponies have been
chosen for their ability to shape the
landscape and scientists will be
measuring their impact over time by
sampling the soil and looking at how
vegetation has been changed by their
grazing
and each species has their own special
skills the Exmore Ponies are our native
breed very wild ponies that will move
around the Woodland quite fast grazing
and picking at different bits of
vegetation our big heavy Longhorn cattle
they're going to pushed through the
undergrowth they're going to use their
horns to break down small trees open up
the ground for wildflowers to come
through
that pride of place is European bison
roaming 50 hectares of space beyond the
fence in what is the first wild bison
project in the UK they love to punch
through this really dense vegetation
opening it up and creating these
live-filled spaces which again is really
great for all different types of plants
and and insects and invertebrates so
everything the Bison do they're having
an impact on the world around them
a world that's slowly Coming Back To
Nature
we're returning to our tree planting
theme have you ever walked along your
street and thought that patch there
could do with a tree well there is out
there a tree sponsorship scheme which
enables you to do just that and also
encourages you to look after it to water
it as well and why wouldn't you want to
do it a lime tree like this fully grown
can store 10 tons of carbon dry weight
that's helping to fight climate change
the group involved sent us this
my name is Simeon I run trees for
streets which is the national Street
tree sponsorship scheme it's a
charity-led initiative a resident
community group or business can select
where they'd like the tree to go using
our online app and if you've chosen to
water the tree we'll also send your
water reminder every week during the
summer for the first three seasons
we're at the Sherwood Primary School in
Mitchum today where one of our kind
sponsors has agreed to sponsor a trees
to go outside in the street
[Music]
that our residence sponsor a tree and
help to increase our tree canopy I
really hope that people club together
with their neighbors and friends and to
join in in our effort to Green Mountain
we work with councils up and down the
country
cities like Bradford Bristol and
Cambridge and in London here we work
with about a third of the London
boroughs
three streets is all about empowering
residents to make where they live better
you get to choose where the tree goes
[Music]
now before we go we've got time to
answer one of your questions and
aliciano got in touch to ask via the Sky
News app why is overpopulation not
considered when discussing the climate
isn't a growing population incompatible
with a finite planet
aliciana asks a very good and a very
hard question
we have to start by acknowledging that
carbon emissions vary widely throughout
the world the average person in the UK
for example where fertility is already
quite low emits about 10 times as much
carbon per year as the average person in
sub-Saharan Africa
often when people invoke concerns about
overpopulation they're thinking of the
rapidly growing and high fertility
countries that are predominantly still
in sub-Saharan Africa
but this is the region of the world
where again the average person emits the
lowest amount of carbon per year and
that is affected the most by climate
change when we think about extreme heat
drought and food insecurity
this doesn't mean we shouldn't support
people to reduce their fertility if they
want to we absolutely should
[Music]
relying on people in poor Nations to
solve a problem that they have
contributed very little to and suffer
the most from is not only unfair but it
also simply won't be as effective as
people in wealthy Nations reducing their
consumption through the solutions that
elysiana raised
and if you have a question you'd like us
to try and answer scan the QR code on
your screen right now
from the show here in Cambridgeshire see
you next week in the meantime I'm off to
enjoy a lovely Woodland walk
foreign
[Music]